[Music]
in some kind of wild and pretty [ __ ]
up news
there was a uh
a gory beach scene very recently
where 30 sea turtles were found stabbed
to death stabbed to death where
dirty
woman just go oh no they just stab them
and that's it where do you think this
happened hawaii
japan oh because they they'd be doing
that how did you know it was japan
because is it like japanese fishermen
are known to be correct me if i'm wrong
uh ryan
[Laughter]
they not kill turtles but like they kill
like random animals well shredder is
japanese so i guess this couldn't this
is a [ __ ]
oh my god they don't just kill them they
don't just kill them for fun they eat
them that's the whole point these were
just what about the baby seals like they
eat them but did they these ones because
they're stores where they just leave
their bodies like the dolphins was that
in japan i don't know if it was japan or
maybe i'm just not racist
it might be racist yeah the whole bloody
dolphin corner thing yeah
just stabbed for fun and just left
that's what i'm saying japanese people
are really suppressed
they should just put all of japan in
therapy huh yes whoa there'll be more
turtles
[Laughter]
the turtle to depression ratio literally
30 more bro they just had therapists
save 30 turtles better help please
so a japanese fisherman has admitted to
stabbing tons of protected sea turtles
to death after beachgoers stumbled
across the horrifying scene oh my god
wow between 30 and 50 green sea turtles
were found dead or dying with stab
wounds to their necks on a beach in
remote
kumejima island lasters aren't they
really rare too are they they're
protected
oh so they're like close they're kind of
endangered or like a medium size um i
would like to say small i wonder why you
did that they're not the huge ones just
a [ __ ] seal killer
wow that is crazy i mean the unnamed
suspect told the local fisherman
cooperative that the turtles got caught
in his fishing nets and then he became
frustrated trying to untangle them so
he's like i'm just gonna kill all these
[ __ ] turtles
dang
suppression he said he released lots of
the sea creatures but after struggling
for so long he began stabbing them to
try and weaken them dude you guys are
more you guys are more mad at this than
the [ __ ] guy who ate people but there
was only one guy because turtles are
nice man that's ratio and the eating the
eating the person seemed like logical he
had already killed and dismembered him
like being curious is not i wish this
guy ate the turtles thank you
yeah i wish he ate the turtles too this
is just wait we're mad he didn't eat the
turtle yeah stab him and leave him yeah
this guy needs to be stabbed o.j shinzon
oh
stupidest status
oh then yeah
that's a little japanese name um so
pretty much uh police are reportedly
investigating the deaths but a source
declined to comment on whether the
fishermen could face punishment actually
they're gonna let them go i forgot to
write a law for them like this isn't
illegal technically loopholes uh the
situation uh they've never seen so many
turtles on his nets
he that he had said the fishman claimed
that he had never seen seen so many
turtles on his nets but now regrets his
actions i actually kind of think to call
[ __ ] a little bit like this he
doesn't regret it yeah i don't think you
find like 30 to 50 turtles in your neck
and
in your neck and it frustrates you so
much when you're trying to release them
yeah that you end up stabbing like more
than five yeah
anyways exactly i mean he says to weaken
them that doesn't make any sense it
doesn't and then they all just wash up
like dead just stabbed in the neck
specifically too that sounds crazy
can we give some can we give some credit
though to who whatever detective cracked
this case
some guy's like looking at the beach
going 30 turtles
o.j shinzon
it's him i know just the thing like how
do you [ __ ] what are the forensics
for that how do you find that guy right
they just see the fisherman over there
with the net god damn turn up
it's not easy
and he goes i think it might be him
you just hear some guy going 31. he's
32. he's like wait there's 30 here and
his assistant's like how do you know
boss
watson
watson in japan yeah they got watson's
uh
[Laughter]
solving japanese crimes
that's what they need csi tokyo i know
it's all crimes that are like it is a
safe country right so their ceo killers
just kill a lot of birds or something
like that cereal or sea we only kill
birds yeah
so according to a doctor isa kawasa who
is a sea turtle expert at the okinawa
research center
um he often hears similar stories from
fishermen saying many say that there are
too many sea turtles that they are
struggling because of it
and he continued that on a global scale
there are not enough sea turtles but
depending on the region the sea turtles
trouble many
oh you know what he snapped he snapped
well he might be doing you know how
there's like hogs yeah i think it's the
same thing but we just like sea turtles
more than hogs yeah we definitely yeah
it's our perspective that you know like
in texas where they do like the hunting
the hogs and stuff it's like get out of
here how they'll like corral them in one
trap but apparently they cause like they
caught they cause like
millions of dollars in damages to the
whole area hugs
and they're invasive
they're not natural to texas right like
they're not they don't hog will [ __ ] you
up too bro yeah but imagine like you try
to fish and feed your family and every
[ __ ] net it's just a bunch of turtles
yeah so why don't you eat the turtle
but i don't want it i killed the turtle
instead you know what i mean that's
pretty sure if you could separate can
you not that's the one is that those are
those are protected also you're not able
to eat them but you can murder them by
stabbing them and then you can't do
either
that's that's probably what's
frustrating is i imagine fishing in an
ocean where they're like protected
species so if you catch them in your
thing you're [ __ ] you're like oh [ __ ]
wanna go fish on the other side
you got a boat take it over there yeah
genius they got all this [ __ ] octopus
back here he's [ __ ] fishing over here
the doctor is right behind us
florida has that problem with iguanas
right yeah dude i heard iguanas be
falling out of the trees why they're
protected no no no they're invasive to
the point where like there's they're
encouraging people to go out and murder
iguanas they're like paying people
aren't they yeah they are or i think
they're just endorsing it oh you know
what i mean like please go out and kill
your iguana
i have a friend that lives out there and
then she was saying that like you know
sometimes in florida that flash storms
so it'll be in the middle of summer and
it's hot and they're cold blooded so
they'll be like a flash storm and it's
like cold for just like a quick 30
minutes or an hour iguanas just [ __ ]
fall from the tree like dude that's what
my sister was saying yeah she lives in
miami too it's just dead yeah and i'll
just slam on your car or whatever they
just [ __ ] fall out of the trees and
[ __ ] the flash storm cloudy with a
chance of iguanas huh yeah i mean i'm
like what the [ __ ] they're everywhere
they get really big apparently so you're
allowed to stab them
no are you not i don't know the iguanas
yeah you can shoot them shoot yeah it's
encouraged to shoot them i think you can
literally kill them in any way that you
uh in florida
it tastes like chicken really yeah
that's why isn't that dangerous
everything tastes like chicken
couldn't you accidentally shoot
something else but if you couldn't hit
in a goal you probably don't want to
shoot in an urban and an urban zone so
green green iguanas are not native to
florida and are considered invasive
species to their impacts to native
wildlife i heard coyotes are like that
too like in california and like
nationwide i hear that's like the only
animal that's in every state in this
nation but they're not native to i think
coyotes are native to north america but
they're in mexico but they're being very
invasive apparently
invasive species are are are animals
that were introduced from foreign like
shipping or like whatever
colonization and all that so then like
boars are one hogs whatever um
and then um in in hawaii they also have
a ton of like [ __ ] boars that come in
you can you can eat them too take them
yeah in japan you remember when there
was the fukushima thingy
so
they were encouraging people
to [ __ ] kill the mutated boars they
were like eating the radioactive food
and getting bigger as [ __ ] with like 20
tusks and [ __ ] they look like rock
stadium bebop oh [ __ ] that's tight and
then shredder was just killing all the
turtles in the [ __ ] side of the
island is there any pictures of these
boars these mutated japanese mutated
boars they look like street sharks yeah
dude i love street sharks they got jeans
on and [ __ ]
they got belt buckles and jeans jeans
and knee pads
clubs
now man dude i'm it biker mice from mars
they're called the wild boars of
fukushima yeah
because they're at all yeah
[ __ ] you up dude they don't look too
crazy but they are just considered
radioactive hybrid terror pigs terror
pigs
that's scary bro imagine if you train
them as like war dogs
dude it's like imagine if you're like
navy seals and then you're yeah warthogs
and you're going down they don't look
that different than like regular they
kind of look [ __ ] up they do kind of
look [ __ ] up his teeth
the assessment
that's a [ __ ] up boar for sure apple's
starting to look like a predator a
little bit that was ugly huh i mean
that's a bad angle the eye looks really
humid though right he looks like yeah he
looks like yeah you got to get a pretty
egg that's not the best angle of any
borer that's true that's his regular
side angle you're just saying he's
[ __ ] up looking that's what you're
saying
what if they're just sad because they've
got radiation
they got radiation they're just they're
all [ __ ] up yeah you know they're just
like they just need counseling dude
they're just like help me
but in japan they're encouraging
everyone all the hunters to just go out
and just shoot as many as you can shoot
them and eat them or just shoot them
again you can't eat them they could have
guns in japan yeah yeah but it's it's
it's straight oh you gotta make it you
gotta have uh oh god you go to a
like a like a tiy shot holds the the
rifles for you
and then you you have to check it out
and then you go cut and then you come
back and you drop it off there yeah nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you